y de cómo todas las modas regresan.
Unas cuantas cervezas más, dije, "tiene que haber alguna cosa
que no haya vuelto". (Risas)
Luego de una cerveza más, ¿qué pasó con el bigote?
¿Por qué no ha regresado? (Risas)
Entonces hubo muchas más cervezas y el día terminó
con el reto para traer de vuelta el bigote. (Risas)
En Australia, "mo" es jerga para bigote,
así que cambiamos el nombre del mes de noviembre, "Movember",
y formulamos algunas reglas muy básicas, que siguen en pie hoy en día.
Son: iniciar el mes bien afeitado,
dejarse un bigote —no una barba, no una chivera, un bigote—
durante los 30 días de noviembre y, a continuación, convenimos
que nos reuniríamos al final del mes,
a celebrar una fiesta temática de bigote, con un premio
para el mejor y, por supuesto, el peor bigote. (Risas)
Créanme, cuando nos dejábamos el bigote,
allá en 2003, y éramos 30 entonces,
y antes del movimiento del irónico bigote 'hipster'
—(Risas)—
se generó mucha controversia. (Risas)
Mi jefe no me dejaba ir a ver clientes.
Mi novia del momento, que ya no es mi novia —(Risas) — lo odiaba.
Los padres alejaban sus hijos de nosotros. (Risas)
Pero llegamos juntos al final del mes
y celebramos nuestra aventura, y fue una aventura real.
Nos divertimos mucho, y en 2004, les dije a los chicos:
"Eso fue muy divertido. Necesitamos legitimarlo
para que podamos llegar lejos con él en un año". (Risas)
Así que empezamos a pensar en ello y fuimos inspirados
por las mujeres alrededor nuestro y todo lo que hacían para el cáncer de mama.
Y pensamos, sabes qué, no hay nada para la salud de los hombres.
¿Por qué? ¿Por qué no podemos combinar el crecimiento de un bigote
con hacer algo para la salud de los hombres?
Y comencé a investigar el tema y descubrí que
el cáncer de próstata es el equivalente masculino del cáncer de mama
en cuanto al número de hombres que mueren de esto y que se les diagnostica uno.
Pero no había nada por esta causa,
así que casamos el dejarse crecer el bigote con el cáncer de próstata,
y, a continuación, creamos nuestro lema, que es:
"Cambiar la cara de la salud de los hombres",
que describe con elocuencia el desafío,
cambiar su apariencia por 30 días,
y también el resultado que estamos tratando de lograr:
hombres comprometidos con su salud, que tienen
una mejor comprensión de los riesgos de salud que enfrentan.
Así que con ese modelo
llamé en frío al director de la Fundación de Cáncer de Próstata.
Le dije: "tengo la idea más maravillosa
que va a transformar su organización". (Risas)
Y como no quería compartirla por teléfono,
lo convencí de reunirse conmigo para tomar café en Melbourne
en 2004.
Nos sentamos y compartí con él mi visión
de conseguir hombres que se dejaran el bigote por toda Australia,
logrando sensibilizar por esta causa
y fondos para su organización. Y necesitaba una asociación
para hacerlo legítimamente.
Y dije: "vamos a llegar juntos hasta el final,
vamos a tener una fiesta temática de bigote, vamos a tener DJs,
vamos a celebrar la vida y vamos a cambiar la cara de la salud de los hombres".
Él solo me miró, se rió y me dijo:
"Adam, es una idea realmente novedosa,
pero somos una organización ultraconservadora.
No podemos tener nada que ver con Uds.". (Risas)
Así que pagué el café ese día —(Risas)—
y su comentario de despedida cuando nos estrechamos las manos fue:
"Escucha, si llegas a conseguir algún dinero,
con mucho gusto lo aceptaremos". (Risas)
Así que mi lección ese año fue persistencia.
Y persistimos, y conseguimos 450 hombres
dejándose el bigote, y juntos recaudamos 54 000 dólares,
y donamos cada centavo a la Fundación de Cáncer de Próstata de Australia,
lo que representó en su momento la donación más grande
de todos los tiempos.
Así que desde ese día, mi vida ha girado alrededor del bigote.
Cada día... esta mañana, me levanté y seguí, mi vida
es sobre un bigote. (Risas)
Esencialmente, soy un agricultor de bigotes. (Risas)
Y mi temporada es en noviembre. (Aplausos)
(Aplausos)
Así que en 2005, la campaña recibió más impulso,
tuvo más éxito en Australia y luego en Nueva Zelanda,
y, después, en el 2006 llegamos a un punto crítico.
Esto consumía tanto tiempo de nuestras horas libres
los fines de semana que pensamos que teníamos o bien
que cerrarlo o lograr una manera de financiar Movember
para que yo pudiera dejar mi trabajo y pasar más tiempo
en la organización y llevarla al siguiente nivel.
Es realmente interesante cuando uno intenta e imagina una forma
de financiar una organización de recaudación de fondos
construida sobre los bigotes. (Risas)
Déjenme decirles que no hay demasiada gente interesada
en invertir en eso, ni siquiera la Fundación de Cáncer de Próstata,
a la que le habíamos conseguido alrededor de 1,2 millones de dólares en ese momento.
Así que de nuevo persistimos, y Foster's Brewing se unió a la fiesta
y nos dio nuestro primer patrocinio,
que fue suficiente para dejar mi trabajo, hice consultoría en paralelo.
Esto nos lleva a Movember 2006,
gastamos todo el dinero de Foster's,
gastamos todo el dinero que tenía, y básicamente
no había quedado nada, y convencimos a todos nuestros proveedores
—agencias creativas, desarrolladoras de web,
compañías de hospedaje y demás— de retrasar sus facturas hasta diciembre.
Así que habíamos acumulado para entonces cerca de 600 000 dólares
en deuda. Por lo que Movember 2006 no se dio,
los cuatro fundadores, bueno, hubiéramos quebrado,
hubiéramos estado en la calle, sentados en la acera
con bigotes. (Risas)
Pero pensamos, sabes qué, si esto es lo peor
que sucede, ¿qué pasa?
Vamos a divertirnos un montón haciéndolo, y esto nos enseñó
la importancia de asumir riesgos y riesgos realmente inteligentes.
Luego, a principios de 2007, sucedió algo muy interesante.
Tuvimos Mo Bros de Canadá, de los EE.UU.
y del Reino Unido, que nos enviaron correos y nos llamaron diciendo:
¡Hola!, no hay nada para el cáncer de próstata.
Traigan esa campaña a estos países.
Así que pensamos, ¿por qué no? Vamos a hacerlo.
Así que llamé en frío al director de Cáncer de Próstata Canadá
y le dije: "tengo el concepto más increíble".
(Risas)
"Va a transformar su organización. No quiero
hablarle de ello ahora, pero ¿podría reunirse conmigo
si vuelo a Toronto?" Así que volé aquí,
nos reunimos en Front Street East, y nos sentamos en la sala de juntas,
y dije: "bien, esta es mi visión, conseguir hombres que se dejen crecer bigotes
por todo Canadá, generar sensibilización y recaudar fondos para su organización".
Me miró, se rió y dijo:
"Adam, suena como una idea realmente novedosa, pero somos
una organización ultraconservadora". (Risas)
He escuchado esto antes. Sé de qué va.
Pero dijo: "Nos asociaremos con Uds.
pero no vamos a invertir en esto. Uds. necesitan encontrar
una forma de traer esta campaña aquí y hacer que funcione".
Así que lo que hicimos fue tomar parte del dinero que
conseguimos en Australia para traer la campaña
a este país, EE.UU., y al Reino Unido, e hicimos esto
porque sabíamos, que si era un éxito,
podríamos reunir infinitamente más dinero mundialmente
del que podríamos reunir solo en Australia. Y ese dinero
potenciaría la investigación que nos llevaría a una cura.
Y no estamos en la búsqueda de una cura australiana
o una cura canadiense, estamos buscando la cura.
Así que en 2007, llevamos la campaña por aquí,
y eso sentó las bases para la campaña.
No fue tan exitosa como pensamos que sería.
Estábamos muy entusiasmados con nuestro éxito en Australia
y Nueva Zelanda en ese momento.
Así que ese año realmente nos enseñó la importancia de ser pacientes
y realmente entender el mercado local antes de
ser muy vivos y poner metas elevadas.
Pero me siento muy satisfecho de decir que en 2010
Movember se convirtió en un movimiento verdaderamente global.
Canadá sola se adelantó en términos de ser
la campaña de recaudación número uno del mundo.
El año pasado tuvimos 450 000 Mo Bros repartidos por todo el mundo
y juntos conseguimos 77 millones de dólares.
(Aplausos)
Y eso hace que Movember sea ahora la mayor fuente de financiación
de investigación del cáncer de próstata y programas de apoyo en el mundo.
Y eso es un logro increíble cuando se piensa en
nosotros dejándonos el bigote. (Risas)
Y para nosotros, ha redefinido la caridad.
Nuestra cinta es una cinta peluda. (Risas)
Nuestros embajadores son los Mo Bros y las Mo Sistas,
y creo que han sido fundamentales para nuestro éxito.
Llevamos nuestra marca y nuestra campaña a estas personas.
Les dejamos adoptarlo e interpretarlo a su manera.
Ahora vivo en Los Ángeles porque
la Fundación de Cáncer de Próstata de los Estados Unidos tiene su sede allí
y siempre me preguntan los medios de comunicación de allá,
porque son muy orientados a las celebridades,
"¿Quiénes son sus celebridades embajadoras?"
Y les digo: "el año pasado tuvimos la suerte
de tener 450 000 celebridades embajadoras".
Y sueltan: "¿Qué, qué dice?"
Y es que cada persona, cada uno de los Mo Bros
y Mo Sistas que participan en Movember
es nuestra celebridad embajadora, y es tan, tan importante
y fundamental para nuestro éxito.
Ahora quiero compartirles
uno de mis más conmovedores momentos Movember,
ocurrido aquí en Toronto el año pasado,
al final de la campaña.
Estaba con un equipo. Fue el final de Movember.
Habíamos tenido una gran campaña, y para ser honesto, habíamos tenido
nuestra dosis justa de cerveza esa noche, pero dije,
"Saben qué, creo nos está faltando un bar". (Risas)
Así que nos apilamos en un taxi, este es nuestro conductor,
yo estaba sentado en el asiento trasero y él dio la vuelta
y dijo: "¿A dónde van?"
Y dije: "¡Espere! Ese es un bigote impresionante".
(Risas)
Y él dijo: "Lo estoy haciendo por Movember". Y dije:
"Yo igual". Y dije: "Cuénteme su historia de Movember".
Y dijo: "Mire, sé que es sobre la salud de los hombres,
Sé que es sobre cáncer de próstata, pero esto es para el cáncer de mama".
Y dije: "Bien, que interesante".
Siguió: "El año pasado, mi mamá murió de cáncer de mama en Sri Lanka,
porque no podíamos costear el tratamiento adecuado para ella",
y dijo: "Este bigote es mi homenaje a mi mamá".
Y estábamos todos conmovidos y en silencio atrás en el taxi
y no le dije quien era, porque pensé que no era apropiado,
y yo solo le estreché la mano y le dije: "Muchísimas gracias.
Su mamá estaría tan orgullosa".
Y desde ese momento me di cuenta de que Movember
es mucho más que un bigote o hacer una broma.
Se trata de cada persona que llega a estos programa,
que lo adopta a su manera,
y le da significado en su propia vida.
Nosotros ahora en Movember, nos enfocamos en
tres áreas del programa para tener un verdadero impacto:
sensibilización y educación,
programas de apoyo a sobrevivientes e investigación.
Ahora bien, siempre nos concentramos en cuánto dinero recaudamos
porque es un resultado tangible, pero para mí,
la sensibilización y educación es más importante que los fondos que recaudamos,
porque sé que es cambiar vidas, salvar vidas hoy,
y probablemente el mejor ejemplo sea
un joven que conocí en 'South by Southwest'
en Austin, Texas, a principios de año.
Se me acercó y dijo: "Gracias por comenzar Movember."
Y dije: "Gracias por hacer Movember".
Y lo miré diciendo: "Estoy seguro de que a Ud. no le crece el bigote". (Risas)
Y dije: "¿Cuál es su historia de Movember?"
Y dijo: "Tuve el peor bigote posible". (Risas)
"Pero me fui a casa para la cena de Acción de Gracias y muy rápidamente
la conversación alrededor de la mesa llevó a
qué demonios estaba pasando". (Risas)
"Y hablamos, hablé con ellos acerca de Movember,
y después de eso, mi papá se me acercó, y a la edad
de 26, por primera vez, tuve una conversación con mi papá
uno a uno sobre la salud de los hombres. Tuve una conversación
con mi papá sobre el cáncer de próstata y supe
que mi abuelo tuvo cáncer de próstata
y pude compartir con mi padre que él tiene
el doble de posibilidades de tener la enfermedad y él lo sabía,
y no se había hecho el examen".
Así que ahora sí se hace el examen de cáncer de próstata.
Así que esas conversaciones, que los hombres se comprometan con esto,
a cualquier edad, es tan críticamente importante,
en mi opinión mucho más importante
que los fondos que recaudamos.
Ahora sobre los fondos que recaudamos, la investigación
y cómo estamos redefiniendo la investigación.
Financiamos fundaciones de cáncer de próstata en 13 países.
Financiamos literalmente cientos si no miles de instituciones
e investigadores alrededor del mundo, y cuando miramos
esto más recientemente, nos dimos cuenta de que hay una falta real
de colaboración, incluso dentro de las instituciones,
aún más a nivel nacional, aún más a nivel mundial, y esto no es exclusivo
del cáncer de próstata. Esto pasa en toda la investigación de cáncer en el mundo.
Por lo que hemos dicho, bien, hemos redefinido la caridad. Necesitamos
redefinir la forma en que estas personas operan. ¿Cómo lo hacemos?
Lo que hicimos fue crear un plan de acción mundial,
y estamos tomando el 10 % de lo que se recauda en cada país,
lo ponemos en un fondo global, y tenemos
las mejores mentes científicas de cáncer de próstata en el mundo
cuidando ese fondo,
y se reúnen cada año e identifican
la prioridad número uno,
y, el año pasado, estaban tras una mejor prueba de detección.
Por lo que lo identificaron como una prioridad y entonces
han conseguido y reclutado a 300 investigadores
de todo el mundo que están estudiando este tema,
esencialmente el mismo tema.
Así que ahora los estamos financiando con
cinco o seis millones de dólares para colaborar
y reunirlos, lo que es algo único
en el cáncer mundial, y sabemos que, a través de esa colaboración,
se acelerarán los resultados.
Así es cómo estamos redefiniendo el mundo de la investigación.
Por lo tanto, lo que sé sobre mi aventura de Movember es que,
con una idea realmente creativa,
con pasión, con persistencia y mucha paciencia,
cuatro compañeros, cuatro bigotes,
pueden inspirar una sala llena de gente,
y esa sala llena de gente puede ir e inspirar a una ciudad,
y esa ciudad es Melbourne, mi hogar.
Y esa ciudad puede ir e inspirar a un estado y ese estado
puede ir e inspirar una nación y más allá de eso,
puede crear un movimiento global
que cambie la cara de la salud de los hombres.
Mi nombre es Adam Garone, y esa es mi historia.
Gracias. (Aplausos)